guys ice poseidon has now issued a
statement that he's innocent that's
right he never scammed people and i got
it wrong yeah that audio of him
admitting everything it's a deep fake
maybe
maybe his haters created it i don't know
either way in his new statement he's not
going to return the money but it's not a
scam it's he's innocent now i'm going to
warn you guys you have to have a very
very high iq for this so if you're not
the leader of your mensa club you click
off this video you you don't belong here
okay very high iqs big brains only i
just want to say this up front to be
fair to ice poseidon one possibility i
did consider is that he might suffer
from extreme memory loss and just maybe
just forgot about his confession a few
days ago that's the only explanation i
have for what we're about to uh hear
here but here's the statement right here
my one and only response to the subject
and then underneath his one and only
response he responded again the post has
a lot of terminology and might be hard
to grasp if you're a noob to crypto but
everything is verifiable and i encourage
people to go check for themselves that's
right ladies and gentlemen it might be a
little hard to understand and if you
still think it's a scam at the end of
this twitlonger you probably don't
understand krypto okay this is how it
works his liquidity pool pre-sell for
coin wallet allowed him to take your
money if you don't understand that
you're not educated
but he says i did not steal or scam
anyone nor did i make money at the
expense of others now this is very
interesting very interesting point ice
poseidon seems to be arguing for the
existence of magical money that a comes
from from nowhere because he admits in
the twitlonger he did make three hundred
thousand dollars but it wasn't at the
expense of anyone apparently thin air i
think is basically his argument first of
all i did not advertise cxcoin to my
casual fans who don't know anything
about crypto guys it's okay he didn't
advertise to the casual fans he only did
to the die-hard fans
the die-hard fans can get scammed guys
it's not
except whoops it took me like two
seconds of looking into this and i
realized oh yeah he did scam his casual
fans too now we have to forgive ice
because remember you know his whole
memory loss thing it's very tough for
him to remember what he did like three
days ago and even harder for him to
remember what he did in october he
tweeted about an nft project to his
whole audience on twitter he was
pitching an nft and shortly after he
pitched it well it rugged the project
took all the money and ran ice poseidon
tells his casual fans
looks like they deleted their socials
and didn't hand out the mints this is
after people bought that's really
unfortunate and i'm sorry to anyone who
looked into these guys on based on his
recommendation the crypto market is
dangerous and i feel pretty stupid now
for promoting this now look i think the
answer here is obvious i think i could
have forgiven this if he only scammed
his die hard fans but the fact that his
casual fans were involved unforgivable
and also he forgot to say that this was
an ad and that he got paid for this
which he told me behind the scenes when
i asked about this but he said he didn't
say that because he figured it was
obvious the same way he figured it was
obvious that this coin was going to be a
scam even though he said it was a
long-term project um it's very
complicated guys very hard to understand
you know what i mean big iqs only and
the next part of the twit longer is the
same on the whole video there was not
one single mention of the main product
which has been fully functional for
months easy tip four dot me i had even
used this on uh some of the streams all
this was built from scratch once again
guys all i can do is apologize for my
carelessness here and tell you that i
did try to use this train wreck before i
made my videos gonna planning on
becoming a full-time twitch streamer
with this revolutionary new crypto
website that allows you to send money
from one person to the other over the
internet yeah um
breaking news but unfortunately the
website wasn't working at the time yeah
when you try to click register on easy
tip for me it says contact us on our
official telegram which ice poseidon
admits was dead so the dead website
requires you to contact a dead telegram
to get it to work this fully functional
fully functional thing and even in the
videos that i found where it was
functional it wasn't functioning
properly people were tipping like
pennies and making it seem like they
tipped millions of dollars and even ice
poseidon seemed to realize like how bad
his platform was at the time
yes gary that was you what
nah see now
now there's a glitch the 2000 is
probably a glitch too then he's probably
that's pr is it it's bro
it says 50 million
so i don't know if i thought it would be
better if i talked more about this
dumpster fire platform which doesn't
work but there you go that's that's
what's going on there now we're about to
hit the crypto jargon section of this
twit longer and i just want to prepare
you because i read this thing many times
guys you guys know i'm a crypto head so
i was trying to understand what he was
saying and you know what i realized you
can translate all of the jargon all of
everything he says into basically one
sentence over and over repeated which is
i'm keeping the money like take this for
example it was completely unnecessary to
have 400 thousand dollars in the lp 264
in the lp 150k in the buyback function
and the money was at risk at getting the
value due to the crypto markets dropping
so you could try to understand that why
it's unnecessary for his fans to have
400 000 why they don't need it or you
could just replace it with i'm keeping
the money it just reads so much better
that way look the whole thing actually
reads better i'm keeping the money i'm
keeping the money i'm keeping the money
i'm keeping the money see it doesn't the
idea gets across so much better now
another amazing part about this too is
the idea that he says right there which
is that he has to take out the money
because the crypto markets are dropping
but when i asked ice poseidon where he
was going to put the money that he took
out of the crypto markets he told me
he's going to put it in the crypto
markets uh invest into crypto ethereum
mainly see it's so obvious guys if you
just have a big brain you have to have a
high iq remember he had to take the
money out of the crypto markets because
that's a terrible investment and the
real place to put the money is in the
crypto markets because that's where the
big money's at now the last thing he
says is that uh i hope these points
clarify some of the misunderstandings
and justify my actions at all times i
will be keeping the money i'm i'm sorry
i will guarantee every cx coin holder is
able to sell their tokens if they wish
to you know the crazy thing to me is
this whole twit longer thing could have
been avoided this whole situation could
have been avoided just by giving the
money back to investors like that's
what's crazy to me you didn't have to do
you know
russian gold medal mental gymnastics to
get out of this thing you could have
just given the money back instead it's
like well the lp and the markets were
crashing and oh i was getting out of it
no no you were just
scamming people that's which is i guess
if that's what you want to do what
you're you're into but uh i think he's
at this point taking away the last
admirable quality about himself with
this latest twit longer which is that
the the first time he talked to me at
least he was honest at least he was an
honest scammer you could say that about
ice poseidon and now he's he's just a
regular scammer